they are not entirely unexpected
consumers are doing what we might expect
and plenty of people watching this
morning will have direct experience of
cutting back where they can we know food
inflation is not falling it is rising so
people have been cutting back elsewhere
that reflected in December's retail
figures in what will be disappointing
definitely to retailers a one percent
full year on year a really striking 5.8
decline in volumes of sales at Christmas
remember we're comparing with Christmas
21 that was the Omicron Christmas when
football on high streets fell so to be
nearly six percent below that level uh
this Christmas just gone really is
striking a few factors beyond inflation
which is still above 10 biting very hard
into household budgets there were
strikes there were rail strikes in
December that 16th 17th of December the
Friday Saturday the last really big
shopping weekend before Christmas well
there were no trains running that
weekend there have been postal strikes
throughout the month too which have had
a big impact on online sales which are
down more than 24 on November so those
because combining the kind of things
people weren't buying they're the things
you might hope to find in your Christmas
stocking Cosmetics sports equipment
games toys watches jewelry all the fun
stuff is where people appear to have
been cutting back in the office of
national statistics say that their
feedback from retailers and from surveys
with consumers is that they're cutting
back because of increased prices and
worries about affordability